[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans son ensemble la population a
répondu à l'appel aux yeux du référendum
et elle a donné au général de gaulle oui
massif qu'il avait demandé à la nation
ce oui populaire d'année à la paix des
accords d'evian le président de la
république l'a concrétisé lui même dans
son bulletin de citoyens colombey les
deux églises
et le premier ministre monsieur michel
debré à montlouis à bord dont c'était le
oui du président de l'assemblée monsieur
chaban delmas dans le jura le oui les
radicaux par la voie des deux garçons si
à marseille le oui de monsieur de fer se
nuancer à arras monsieur guy mollet a
porté le oui des socialistes comme à
lille monsieur maurice schumann le oui
du mrp
le bulletin de ne souhaiterait ce
n'était pas des réserves des communistes
et celui de monsieur pinet de celle des
indépendants
dans la nuit les tableaux du ministère
de l'intérieur ont suivi le déroulement
du dépouillement 17 millions 500 mille
oui pour 19 millions 300 mille suffrages
exprimés et monsieur roger frey pourrait
annoncer aux journalistes le record des
ouïes près de 91%
voyage éclair à turin le général de
gaulle poursuivant ses pourparlers avec
les nations voisines est allé
s'entretenir avec le chef du
gouvernement italien monsieur fin
famille
[Musique]
les deux hommes d'état au cours de leur
examen des problèmes internationaux se
sont surtout attachés à rapprocher leurs
points de vue sur la formation de la
future europe politique si leur tête à
tête n'a pas donné officiellement de
résultats concrets on voit poindre
maintenant entre l'europe intégrée et
l'europe des patries un espoir de
compromis
[Musique]
détente dans les relations franco
égyptienne le colonel nasser a libéré
les diplomates français que contre toute
justice il avait fait traduire devant
ces tribunaux monsieur mattei et ses
compagnons donc retrouvés à orly leurs
familles paris et le caire ont ils
renouvellent leur relation interrompue
[Musique]
et l'algérie nouvelle commence à
s'organiser au rocher noir monsieur
christian fouchet haut-commissaire de
france a installé l'exécutif provisoire
dans le président est monsieur
abderrahmane farès qui fut autrefois
président de l'assemblée algérienne la
distribution des responsabilités
maintenant officiel les douze
commissaires ont pris possession de
leurs fonctions et le président du
nouvel organisme a ouvert la première
séance de travail
[Musique]
enfin
ça fait
le fond des mers livrera-t-il bientôt
ses secrets c'est avec l'ambition de les
lui arracher en tout cas que le super
bathyscaphe archimède de la marine
française s'est embarqué à toulaud très
prosaïquement du reste sur le cargo
maori destination yokohama japon là bas
il entreprendra des essais qui le
conduiront entre 10 et 11 mille mètres
de profondeur sous le pacifique
aux états unis on vise plus haut la lune
exactement la future capsule du projet
apollon qui sera occupé non plus par un
nez par trois astronautes ce qui leur
permettra de moins s'ennuyer a été
présentée très officiellement le système
d'alimentation par pub a lui aussi été
expérimenté tout semble paré il reste il
est vrai à mettre au point la fusée est
le moteur qui permettront non seulement
d'alunir mais de repartir
quoi qu'il en soit on nous promet la
lune pour 1968
[Musique]
et
ala cimaises de la galerie david et
garnier paris affronté récemment une
scène peu orthodoxes ou judas tourner le
dos au christ et aux autres à pau ils
découvraient ainsi un nouveau buffet un
buffet mystique à la suite des matisse
le corbusier cocteau le jeune peintre
abordait à son tour l'art sacré à sa
manière en noir jaune et rouge
on aime ou on n'aime pas cette peinture
sombre et brutal on fut d'accord portant
sur la prodigieuse faculté d'envoûtement
de ces visages tragique
cette exposition avait aussi une autre
signification elle soulignait
l'extraordinaire réussite du mari
d'annabelle
[Musique]
à 32 ans il s'offrait le luxe d'exposer
des toiles dont chacune aurait pu être
acheté des millions et dont aucune
n'était à vendre 15 ans ont suffi pour
en arriver là
autour des années 48 bernard buffet
n'était encore qu'un adolescent inconnu
qui flamme est devant notre dame et sur
qui personne ne se retournait
c'était le temps du petit bistrot où les
habitués le patron bienveillant et
bourru accueille gentiment ce garçon qui
barbouillent est des toiles dans le
quartier un jour peut-être pourquoi pas
on parlerait de lui mais dans combien
d'années dans la peinture qui ne le sait
le temps des oeufs durs peut aussi bien
durer toute une vie moins de quinze ans
séparent pourtant le bistrot des
batignolles est la propriété du château
l'arc près d'aix en provence
[Musique]
bernard buffet et annabelle comme
picasso à 80 ans sont devenus chapin au
milieu de leurs bibelots d'un courrier
qui arrivent des quatre coins du monde
ils se sont réservés à luxe
supplémentaire le bistrot reconstitué du
temps tout proche où la gloire et la
fortune d'aujourd'hui n'étaient même pas
imaginable
le château le parc le chenil
quels sont aujourd'hui les signes d'une
réussite foudroyante dont on aimerait
penser qu'elle est un peu la revanche
des peintres voué à la misère d'un
gauguin d'un van gogh d'un maudit
guyenne
[Musique]
sportif américain honteuse aussi leurs
hommes de l'espace cet homme c'est le
sauteur à la perche john huston on ne
sait pas s'il ya des limites aux
exploits de cet athlète qui a frisé 5
mètres à plusieurs reprises son record
du monde 4 m 89 exactement il est vrai
que la perche qui l'utilisent ressemble
étrangement à une cata plus
pour le racing club de paris en maillot
blanc que l'autre noir et pour
saint-etienne ce match du parc des
princes et le match de la dernière
chance le racing joue le titre de
champion de france quant à saint-etienne
il joue son maintien actuellement fort
compromis en première division
très entreprenant maniant la contre
attaque avec beaucoup de verve les
stéphanois prennent avantage sur un tir
de riches versent
tout cela un peu contre le cours du jeu
le racing en effet pratiquer un football
beaucoup plus collectif le ballon voyage
d'un joueur à l'autre il est vrai
cependant que toutes les actions des
parisiens manquent de vitesse
ils parviennent cependant à égaliser
deuxième mi temps rien ne change le
racing domine outrageusement et de temps
à autres saint-etienne contre attaque
comme en ce moment trois relais de balle
successifs et c'est suffisant aux
stéphanois pour marquer un second but et
gagner ainsi un match qui leur permet
d'attendre l'avenir avec un peu moins
d'inquiéter
lorsque les allemands se met la bague au
doigt ce n'est pas toujours pour le bon
motif à preuve les munichois sont très
friands de ce genre d'exercice c'est
très reposant comme spectacle spectacle
plein de situations cocasses
et pourtant tout ceci est fort sérieux
il s'agit ici d'un championnat officiel
jeu spore n'exige pas de qualités
intellectuelles particulière il suffit
de mettre son doigt dans un anneau et de
tirer du plus fort qu'on peut jusqu'à ce
que l'adversaire large pris
de bons muscles et une certaine capacité
de résistance à la douleur voilà les
qualités qu'il faut pour faire un
champion
tous les moyens sont permis à condition
que la table les tabourets soit assez
solide solide également doivent être les
concurrents qui risquent souvent la
chute et il paraît qu'il ya tout de même
à vainqueur il ya des subtilités qui
nous échappe
[Musique]